(patriotic instrumental music)
- By ratifying this
declaration, we hereby denounce
all allegiance to
the British crown.
- Here, here!
- Boo!
- Mr. Trump from New
York, you wish to speak?
- Oh, shut it Jefferson.
You know I'm Trump now, alright.
Look delegates, you know
me, you know I'm rich,
and you know that I'm
wonderfully dressed
and I'm extremely
knowledgeable at business,
and I gotta tell you, this
declaration deal, it's horrific.
It's one of the worst
deals I've ever seen.
It's a real joke job, alright?
It's messy, it's got
signature all over it
and if I was
president, I promise,
I would make these
colonies great again, okay?
Okay, folks.
You know Jefferson, you know
Adams, and you know Franklin,
and frankly they're pussies.
They're all pathetic, they
are some of the worst.
The way that they bungled
that whole tea tax thing,
disgusting.
If I was there, I'd
be getting teabagged
by every freakin'
red coat I saw.
- They imposed taxes
without our consent.
That is why we are
fighting this war, Trump!
- Excuse me, ugly Adams.
Don't you mean that's why
we're losing this war?
Because we are, you lost Quebec.
You lost Bunker
Hill, you're a loser.
Under a Trump Administration,
I would be winning so much
you'd be sick of winning.
You'd feel like
you had diphtheria.
It would be disgusting,
you'd be pooping and
peeing everywhere.
I can promise you that.
- You blusterous blow-heart.
What qualifies you to lead
the continental army?!
- I am gonna make a
tremendous deal on guns.
I'm friends with all the Blacks.
Smiths, they love
me, I love them.
We get along very well.
We have a secret
handshake, okay.
- Mr. Trump, with
all due respect,
this congress is
perfectly capable
of providing security
for its citizens.
- Oh is it, fat Franklin?
I don't think it is
'cause Mexico owns
half of the continent
last time I checked
and if I was elected,
I'd build a wall around Mexico
and I'd have China pay for it.
'Cause China loves walls
and China loves me.
I've been to China,
they love me more
than their Chinese spaghetti.
- That is racist sir,
even in this time period.
- Do we really want
the man who organized
the Miss Colonies Pageant
to lead our new nation?!
- I do not!
- Oh yeah, speaking of which,
have you seen my
new wife Morenca?
Oof, she's a real smoke show.
She's got titties
like I've never seen.
Unlike Jefferson's
wife, she's a fat pig.
I heard she's so ugly that
he has sex with his slaves.
I don't know, is it true?
- Big words from a man
with such small hands!
- If my farm hands were small,
that means my plantation is
small and I could assure you,
I don't have any problems
in that department, okay?
- Gentlemen, I must
ask, no more quarreling.
It is time that we made a
meal of this declaration.
- Look, alright guys,
let me get to the point.
I say instead of making
America great again,
we make America,
Great Britain again.
Alright, okay, okay.
Alright, look, okay.
Who threw that?
Who threw that,
someone punch him.
I will pay your
magistrate fees, alright?
Look, don't come running
to me in 240 years
when you need my family to
save your country, alright?
- I assure you, Mr. Trump,
the democracy will never
be in that bad of shape.
(laughter)
- That's what fat
Franklin's wife said.
Alright, Trump 76.
Vote Trump, Trump Palin.
(patriotic instrumental music)